[Music]
well hello friends we're so glad that
you decided to join us for our weekly
program I'd like to know it's a short
program only approximately 20 5 minutes
but uh we take the time to do research
on questions that you send us and then
we share uh the results of our research
uh we want to once again thank you for
being with us and we also want to thank
you for your support not only your
financial support which makes these
programs possible but also and
especially your prayers amen We crave
your prayers because that is what makes
our ministry continue on the right track
amen uh I want to give you the email
address where you can send the questions
to us you'll see it on the screen it's
TV at some tv.org once again tvom tv.org
please send us your questions be patient
because we receive many questions we
answer them in the order in which they
come I have with me a very good friend
fellow worker here in the Lord's cause
at Secrets unsealed and some TV Pastor
David Salazar uh glad you're here thank
you thank you Pastor a privilege as
always to be with you praise the Lord
okay well we want to have a word of
prayer and then we'll jump right into
the questions today which are very good
ones absolutely let so Pastor pray for
us please absolutely let us pray our
gracious Heavenly Father we are once
again delighted that we can come to your
throne of grace and to know that you are
a giver of all good things especially
the gift of the Holy Spirit and we know
Lord that you have told us that if we
ask for that special gift you will
provide to us and we ask that you will
give us that Spirit to understand
clearly your word to be able to express
and to share not our thoughts not our
words but your words and your thoughts
that way the answer may bring Comfort
light to those that are watching and
listening and once again we thank you
for allowing us to know you and for
being part of this your ministry we pray
this in Jesus name amen amen uh the
first question that we have I believe
that we've had before here at secret
unsealed in some TV if I remember
correctly however because the person
sent it in uh we want to provide a brief
answer to it it's based on 1
Thessalonians chapter 5 and verse 23 and
I'm wondering Pastor if you could please
read that uh vers Absol 1 Thessalonians
chapter 5 and verse 23 I believe it is I
have it here yes you're correct the
person the person that does not put the
reference but uh if my mind doesn't fail
me that's it you are very clear is
actually that same verse is mentioned
first Thessalonians 5:23 and Paul is
telling us this and the Very God of
Peace sanctify you holy and I pray God
your whole spirit and soul and body we
preserve blameless unto the coming of
the of our Lord Jesus Christ so how do
we you know the the question is uh is
man composed of three separable parts
and can one part function independently
of the other so how do we understand
this verse well thankfully the Lord is
actually giv us an a very clear
definition of what composes the human
being it's not three individual aspects
or elements but the three elements of of
what constitutes a person is really
presented in here we have body which is
the physical
you know actual Corporal thing that we
see that we have then we have as he says
the spirit now the spirit is in regards
to the Mind where our thoughts or
emotions everything that is there in our
mind what makes us think reason so the
word spirit is in in this connection
linked to our mind and then we have the
word Soul connected to the spiritual
aspect of Our Lives that which is necess
Neary for us to have uh connection with
God so it really speaks of our physical
or spiritual and our mind you know these
three elements there in the verse 23 so
the bottom line is that one cannot
function without the other yeah you
cannot have because because you know
your physical body has a
brain and through your brain you think
but through our brain also we have a
relationship with God absolutely and so
they are not mutually separate able
Parts what the text is telling us is
that God sanctify us completely right
physically mentally and spiritually
right you know uh in our University in
Columbia where I taught for six years
they have this this Monument it's an
obelisk some people say oh an obelisk
you know that's so C well obelisks were
just popular at that time but the abesa
actually has three sides one side says
mano the other side says M and the other
side says coron yeah uh B hand which is
the body body right mind and heart right
and so and it's only one Monument so the
the lesson is that uh we are a Unity
there's no such thing as a soul within
our body that can function independently
of our physical body right that's not
what Paul is saying here in this verse
and and you know Pastor also an
important point is that as much as men
could for example atheists those that
try to deny the need of a spiritual
connection always they find themselves
with some need that is not mentally or
is not physically there's that element
in every human person that needs to have
that experience with God and so this is
why no matter how much you may try to
reason things out and reason you know go
through philosophy and trying to just be
a very reasonable or use facts to create
believe in things there's always this
element in the human experience that is
that what Paul says of soul but is
really the spiritual need of a person
that is something that has not been able
to be put away from the experience of
man because it's there God put it there
for us for our need and God wants us to
live a balanced life absolutely you know
there there are individuals who live
only on the physical level they try like
like sports people you know not not all
of them but some of them live only on
the physical level Scholars live only on
the mental level and then monks live
only on the spiritual level and what God
wants us is to develop all three in
Balance all three that we care for our
body that we care for our mind and that
we have a devotional life where we have
a relationship with the Lord only then
do we have a fully balanced Christian
experience and experience as a human
being as a whole really you know and
find beauty and joy in being alive in
being a human person because you have
the three elements that God has given us
amen well uh that's a brief answer uh
because we have dealt with it before the
the next question is a complicated one
yeah and I'm not sure that there's a
good solution to the problem I have read
a book that somebody wrote on this
particular Point uh but uh I I still I
still had questions after I read the
book uh it has to do with the
International Date Line MH uh you know
with a problem uh between two places let
me just read it yes hi I would like your
help to fully understand the Sabbath day
in
Tanga uh that's in the South Pacific I
understand the role of the 180 degree
Meridian which is the line that dictates
the days in the two hemispheres
Tonga belongs to the Western Hemisphere
together with America and yet it kept
the day's name and time of the Eastern
Hemisphere simply because of the
International Date Line even though
Tonga kept the days of the Eastern
Hemisphere when it comes to Sabbath it
kept the day sequence of the western
hemisphere in order to keep the Sabbath
day in reality Tonga worship on the same
day with countries in the Western
Hemisphere even even though the name of
the day is different in Tanga compared
to countries in the Western Hemisphere
my question is something to do with the
sun in the Bible the sun is the factor
that determines the day sequence and not
the 180 180 Dee Meridian or the
International Date Line If this is the
determining factor for the Sabbath do
you think it is biblical for Tonga to
keep a different Sabbath day to Fiji
even though Fiji is 1 hour behind Tonga
and the sunlight reached these two
countries 1 hour apart so so it's a very
complicated situation the International
Date Line makes things very
complicated uh when it comes to the
observance of the Sabbath and it's also
very complicated when you travel yes as
I found I've gone to Australia and New
Zealand and and uh to Thailand and man
to get your brain used to the time
change is just uh very difficult um so
what can we say about this uh you know I
I haven't solve the issue in my own mind
you know Pastor as you mentioned it is a
little bit of a complicated issue there
is elements in in favor in both views if
you will you know should we should they
for example keep the seventh day of the
week and in this case would follow in in
maybe on Sunday or should they keep what
is called Saturday and you know you know
it would probably mean that the week was
cut short so these are elements that are
are difficult to deal with and I would
try to persuade our friend to actually
to maybe do some research the Adventist
Church has made enough resources
available to sort of present the view
the argument that can best suit an
answer or give the person the decision
to follow according to what they have
studied I believe that in the multi of
councel there's wisdom and I believe
that this situation was addressed in a
way that the church saw it to be solved
in
a I guess solomonic way if I could say
that way you know what makes more sense
to the church and and in that sense I
would like to direct that person to
follow the advice of the General
Conference Church you know what they
have decided is to me would make more
sense because again like you said there
are too many variables you know I
remember traveling as you mentioned to
the you know Far East and then you lose
a day completely you know you you lose a
day so uh you get it back when you come
when you get it back when you come so
what happens to that L day unfortunately
you know that's an element that that
really creates this confusion or these
issues so uh that's where I feel that
more than trying to go over the this
debate you know there is again a a a
actual article and several articles in
the Adventist Church uh website that
deals with this issue in a way that
maybe can solve all the elements or at
least explain why this church took a a
decision on this matter uh well I want
to recommend a source probably the
person who asked the question it seems
to be this person uh Lenny is very
well-versed on this issue and by the way
it's caused a lot of division yeah uh in
that area because uh you know there's
basically some that say that it needs to
be kept one way and others say that it's
to be kept another different way uh but
Ellen White provided some wise counsel
uh which I think uh is very valuable
it's chapter 40 of uh selected messages
volume three and uh it actually begins
on page
317 of uh volume three of selected
messages I just want to read the first
paragraph the the subtitle is the
Sabbath made for a round world because
you also have the problem of the polar
regions yes you know I've been I've been
to uh a gnome in the winter in Alaska
wow uh where you have in the winter time
you have 20 hours of
darkness in the summertime you have 20
hours of light right you know people are
doing doing their grocery shopping at
3:00 in the morning and it's bright as
day uh so uh you know how do they keep
the Sabbath say in the winter when you
have 20 hours of Darkness how do they
keep the Sabbath in the summer when they
have 20 hours of light MH uh well Ellen
White provides this wise counsel uh in
uh this this is actually letter uh 167
1900 but it it's in volume three of um
selected messages God rested on the
seventh day and set it apart for man to
observe in honor of his creation of the
heavens and the Earth in six literal
days he blessed and Sanctified and made
holy the day of rest when men are so
careful to search and dig to see in
regard to the precise period of time we
are to say God made his Sabbath for a
round world and when the seventh day
comes to us in that round World
controlled by the Sun that rules the day
it is the time in all countries and
lands to observe the sabbath in the
countries where there is no sunset for
months and again no Sunrise for months
the period of time will be calculated by
records kept the Lord accepts now here's
a a really key Point yeah the Lord
accepts All The Obedience of every
creature he has made according to the
circumstances of time in the sunrising
and sunsetting World mhm God takes into
account the
difficulties that exist in Tanga uh and
and the other places there uh God
sometimes accepts our our best service
to him when we have dilemmas that appear
to be insolvable so once again the Lord
accepts All The Obedience of every
creature he has made according to the
circumstances of time in the sunrising
and sunsetting world the Sabbath was
made for a round world and therefore
obedience is required of the people that
are in perfect consistency with the
Lord's created world Amen uh so I
believe that this is very wise councel
there are many other statements that we
find here in this chapter which are
helpful I think in uh understanding a
little bit more about what's happening
there and you know pastor this is why I
think that the recommendation by the
church for specifically Tonga is to
worship on that same 7day cycle you know
because the Lord blessed the seven day
Sabbath and even though the government
did that change and and moved you know
and took away uh a Friday completely you
know out of the calendar to adjust the
actual cycle would give them the 7day
Sabbath on what they call Sunday now you
know but the church affirms that that is
the day that they should worship because
it continues with a 7day cycle the
Sabbath even though the government
changed it to another day so I I think
that if we were to lean with using that
Council for Spirit prophecy the decision
made by the church makes the most
biblical sound uh and makes more sense
okay very good I wish we had a more
definitive answer but uh uh you know
we've done the best we can under the
circumstances yes so now we want to go
to our next question we have about eight
minutes left in our program uh this is
sent by
ion um and he says that he's writing
from New York
so this is the question a question came
to mind this morning during the mission
story reading at church when the main
character in The Mission Story the son
was defending his position in keeping
the Commandments including the Sabbath
with the priest when they got to the
first and second commandments the priest
said to the effect that they're
Justified the Catholic church is
Justified in having and bowing and
worshiping images because Moses erected
this bronze snake for the snake bitten
uh victims in the wilderness to look up
to and be saved and healed in other
words Moses used an image as a symbol of
God so they are justified in doing the
same thing I know and understand the
story as it pertains to Jesus taking our
sins and was lifted up on the cross so
we need to look up to him that be that
became sin for us and be saved but if
you were talking to a priest how would
you push back on his position I may not
see your live broadcast when this is
answered so would you please send a link
or a video or email answer so we'll have
to ask um we'll have to ask Bruce to do
that for this uh person who is asking
the question so uh the question is is
there a difference between God
commanding Moses to raise a serpent uh
bronze Serpent and the Roman Catholic
Church practice of uh making idols and
bowing before them well let's first uh I
think that's important to remember or
when we speak with a somebody that
believes in Idols or believes in these
Concepts like priests to point them to
the scriptures that Christ himself
explained what the purpose of that
serpent was you know in in John 3:14 he
mentions that as Moses lifted up The
Serpent and the Wilderness even so the
son of man must be lifted up now did
the children of Israel use that symbol
of the serpent in a way that was other
than the way the way that was destined
by the Lord eventually they did and that
is why the Lord made them to destroy the
serpent they didn't keep the serpent for
long because it was they were worshiping
the serpent they became yeah they
started worshiping the serpent they
started to follow into the same Pagan
practices so the Lord had to had that
serpent be destroyed and he was not kept
by the Jewish system I mean the Lord
didn't use that serpent ever again it
was only a symbol for them to understand
who Christ was appointing them to this
Redeemer to the Savior it was actually
melted exactly melted well yeah that's
what it was it was melted so because of
that uh we have to remind that priest
say you know God never elected that to
be a permanent display or a permanent uh
symbol of Jesus it was only a temporal
experience for them because of their
need and
as the Lord saw that they were going to
Incline themselves or continue into
idolatry he had that serpent be uh
melted Christ in his word in his uh you
know in the in the in the Commandments
clearly defines the prohibition to
worship images idols and that is
repeated all over the Bible it's not
just in the Old Testament or in the ten
commandments so therefore I think that
you just need to approach this
individual this priest with the
arguments from the word of God and let
the word of God bring conviction to that
man I would ask the priest does God
speak out of both sides of his
mouth right does God say in the first
two Commandments don't make images don't
bow before them yeah and then God
contradicts the first and second
commandment says make a serpent and Bow
Down and Worship it the fact is that the
story does not say that the people
worshiped the serpent yeah it was never
to be or that they bowed to the serpent
yeah they were to look to the serpent
you know we're dealing with typology
right what appeared in the Peri what
happened in the period of the types does
not justify doing now in the time of the
Fulfillment right you know the Bible
says that Jesus is the rock so does that
mean does that mean that we make an idol
out of a rock MH and worship Jesus
Through The Rock no these were symbols
in the Old Testament that had the
purpose of pointing to Christ once
Christ came you didn't need the symbols
you know the Mana uh was Sy symbolic the
water that came from The Rock was
symbolic The Rock was symbolic 1
Corinthians chapter 10 in verses 1-4h so
God doesn't speak out of both sides of
his mouth right uh and uh they did not
bow down they did not worship it and
when they started worshiping it God said
this was not the intention destroy it
exactly that in itself is the best
argument for this priest uh it's amazing
how religious
leaders will pick and choose Bible
verses of the Bible to justify what they
believe we are not supposed to go to the
Bible to prove what we believe we are
supposed to go with an open mind to the
Bible pleading with the Holy Spirit
please show me what your will is and
then God is going to reveal what he
wants us to believe mhm we we are not
called upon to impose our views and
justify our practices by the Bible we
are to put our lives in harmony with the
testimony of the Bible and and you know
the Apostle Paul time and time again had
to deal with people who were pagans who
had been into idolatry and was it was
always this experience of teaching them
revealing to them the truth of the word
of God that there is only one God in
heaven that our worship should be only
to him and not to any image not to
anything that can be made down on the
earth or you know using elements of the
of of of of human hands so this is why
this experience of idolatry that the
priests in this case or Catholic people
use to say we can have Idols we can have
images of Mary images of Jesus to
worship them what not it's really
because they don't really see or are
willing like you said pastor to read the
scripture and let the whole scriptures
explain to them what it says just
picking and choosing and you know
history proves that the church first
started making pictures Etc just
basically for adornment and then in the
process of time yeah these objects
became objects of worship they weren't
there to teach lessons they were there
and became objects of worship so we
recommend that the Catholic Church do
what they did with a serpent that was
raised in the wilderness exactly once
people started bowing and worshiping
before it then they should destroy all
these icons and all these images that
people bow to because people have uh
misunderstood the purpose for which they
were created and it's really a dishonor
to the Lord because God is so much much
greater so much more wonderful than
anything that can be made by your human
hands I mean it's really not knowing who
the Lord is and I believe that's why the
experience in many of these people who
have these Idols to worship it is really
a lack of knowing Christ a lack of
really experiencing the beauty or the
and the uniqueness of having a communion
with God Amen well our time is gone uh
it always goes fast when we're having a
great time studying God's word thank you
for joining us we appreciate it please
pray for us please help us financially
so we can continue producing these
programs God bless you you hope to see
you next time and I'd like to
[Music]
know